in the four years you were making after
we leave how are you balancing you your
professor at Occidental College here in
Los Angeles or Eagle Rock and you have a
family you have children how are you
balancing all that it's a lot the truth
is I think that that balance is never
perfect I often joke that what I think
doesn't get talked about enough is that
the stage of life loose that I'm in
right now is I don't know that I do
anything as well as I wish that I could
but I'm just trying to get all of it to
at least be pretty good being a dad
being a professor being a husband being
a filmmaker
they all have their demands every one of
them is awesome I wouldn't give up any
of them but know for sure making this
movie is one of the most difficult
things ever done and I don't say that
actually looking for pity but more like
I think they just should be a more
candid acknowledgement of how hard it is
to balance those things you know for
part of this movie I was like I was a
part-time professor part-time
stay-at-home dad and trying to make a
feature and then you know now I'm a full
professor at full-time professor at
Occidental and you know I have two kids
now instead of one when I started and
for sure yeah like that balance is
difficult in so many ways in terms of
just time when can you get free to do it
in terms of just resources you know
those other things there's just spending
money and that sort of stuff and then
we're generally the the hardest one I
find is the shift in mindset that if I
were to really encapsulate the phase of
life I'm in right now it's having to
shift gears and sort of take off
different hats and put different hats on
with no real transition points so to go
from dad to Professor to filmmaker
it's a dad you know around that there's
no mental space to sort of flip over and
I'm just accepted I think I just worry
it where I am right now and I think
there's this image of like filmmaking
that is almost like it's divorced from
the rest of life but again you know I
think that this is the reality of
independent cinema and every filmmaker I
know knows this I actually we should
talk about it more which is to say if
you were feeling like man it's really
hard to like you know pack that lunch
for the kid and then they go to your job
and Mikey's like teach this lesson
correctly and then make it to set on
time and shoot the
shot having remembered everything you
needed and being in a state of mind to
be creative you feel like that's
difficult I want to say like yeah it is
difficult and I don't know who we're
kidding if we're saying it's not and and
and to me like and that's fine like I
think that like that struggle is a
reality and so I'm just trying to
maximize it and optimize it but I don't
think it's gonna go hey yeah I see too
much of this mindset of like I got this
and I can talk you know I know this
doesn't you know and I wish sometimes
people were more transparent with no
this is really tough and yeah I don't
know if I do have it but I'm still gonna
show up and I think it's important to
acknowledge that again because I think
it it it's an the amount of time you can
devote to filmmaking
I do think becomes a representation of
an amount of privilege that you have and
I think it is important for us to
recognize by the way that it is actually
harder for different people to get that
half a day to even shoot a scene that
I'm talking you know that I'm talking
about or you get an hour to do that and
that big societal things like that are
part of the reason for the
representation gap in behind the camera
and in front of the camera and that
that's why it's hard to address these
things you know that it can't just be
all open up our application process or
open up our you know how receptive we
are at other ideas that's awesome but
you can have removed a lot of barriers
to entry and still larger sort of
structural problems in like society can
be altering who even tries to step
through those doors that's a really good
point I think that relates to interning
as well even though you know there's a
lot of backlash about interns they hire
industry is I think built on this idea
of well we have all these dreamers and
the ones are the most passionate they'll
come and put in the time and I have to
be honestly again I don't say this to
have any judgment against any individual
who says that but I think it's
reflective of a structural bias that if
you have a system where the measure of
like whether someone is deserving is
they prove it to you about how much time
they put in that is equivalent to saying
your system is structurally biased
against people who at who for who time
is a greater resource a harder to find
resource and that's gonna be women
people of color people of lower income
and so we have to be careful about I
think it is always
important to judge passion and to see
who's serious about what they want to do
but measuring that through certain
metrics will be abused in the past I do
think contributes to the homogeneity of
the industry single moms single dads
exactly and even if they do have time
are they gonna be so tired exactly that
they can't finish it yeah I think that's
one thing that you don't think about
when you're younger is oh yeah I can
totally do this like as balance all the
stuff you don't realize how tired you're
going to be and and you can't think
clearly you know and I think that's some
yeah anyway that's another video
you